Shelly control here again. Earlier in the flight, you recall at the start of the second revolution.
We had a reference to several objects that the crew spotted. This was in the area of Antigua.
Due to a mechanical breakdown, we did not have that portion of the tape available for you.
This was a line breakdown between building 30 and our new center, building 6.
Since then, we have dubbed the tape off the master tape here in the control center, and we are now prepared to play it for you.
It contains references to citing not only some particles, but as well as an unidentified object,
plus the booster. Here's that tape we'll play it for you now.
I Gemini 7 here, you are not here, 8.
Lot and clear, 7, go ahead.
Count those units in a crown tie.
This is Houston, say again 7.
So we have a boat here in T-c crown tie.
Roger.
7 is that the booster, or is that an actual citing?
1.
Say again 7.
You have any more information as to make distance or size?
We also have the booster inside.
Under your stand, you have many small particles going by on the left, at what distance?
Roger, understand there are about 3 to 4 miles away?
Roger.
7.
Houston, or these particles in addition to the booster and the bogey at 10 o'clock high?
Roger.
What direction is it from you?
That mean it's ahead of you?
Roger.
No parts, I don't want to...
I'm one second.
Should we control here again?
The reference in that conversation, the third end of the unidentified object, of course,
was, or the third object, was bogey.
There were several references to the bogey.
This is the unidentified object in addition to particles which appear to be headed in a polar orbit.
You heard Frank Mormon say, plus Jim Lowell discussing the booster.
It was Mormon who reported citing the bogey.
This is Germany controlled Houston at four hours, twenty-four minutes into the flight.